this is where i grew up
a small village near the city of
rotterdam in the netherlands
in the 1970s and 1980s when i was a
teenager
this area was still a quiet place it was
full of farms and fields
and swarmland and i spent my my
free time there enjoying myself painting
oil paintings like this one
collecting wildflowers bird watching and
also
collecting insects and this was one of
my prize
finds this is a very special beetle an
amazing beetle called an
ant beetle and this is a kind of beetle
that lives its entire life
inside an ant's nest it has evolved
to speak and it's using the same
chemical signals the same smells as the
ants do for communicating
and right now this beetle is telling
this worker and hey
i'm also a worker ant i'm hungry please
feed me and the end
complies because the beetle is using the
same chemicals
over these millions of years this beetle
has evolved a way to live
inside an end society
over the years when i was living in that
village i collected
20 000 different beetles and i built
a collection of pinned beetles and this
got me interested at a very early age
in evolution how do all those different
forms how does all this diversity come
about
so i became an evolutionary biologist
like
charles darwin and like charles darwin i
also
soon became frustrated by the fact that
evolution
is something that happened mostly in the
past we study
the patterns that we see today trying to
understand
the evolution that took place in the
past but we can never
actually see it taking place in real
time we cannot
observe it as darwin himself already
said
we see nothing of these slow changes in
progress
until the end of time has marked the
lapse of ages
or do we over the past few decades
evolutionary biologists have come to
realize that sometimes
evolution proceeds much faster and it
can actually be
observed especially when the environment
changes drastically and the need to
adapt
is great and of course these days
great environmental changes are usually
caused by us
we mow we irrigate we plow we
build we pump greenhouse gases into the
atmosphere that change the climate
we release exotic plants and animals in
places where they didn't live before
and we harvest fish and trees and
game for our food and other needs
and all these environmental changes
reach their
epicenter in cities
cities form a completely new habitat
that we have created
and we clothe it in brick and concrete
and glass and steel which are impervious
surfaces
that plants can only root in with the
greatest difficulty
also in cities we find the greatest
concentrations of chemical pollution
of artificial light and noise
and we find wild mixtures of plants and
animals from all over the world
that live in the city because they've
escaped from the gardening and aquarium
and pet trade and what does
a species do when it lives in a
completely
changed environment
well many of course go sadly extinct
but the ones that don't go extinct they
adapt in spectacular
ways biologists these days are beginning
to realize that
cities are today's pressure cookers of
evolution these are places
where wild animals and plants are
evolving under our eyes
very rapidly to suit these new urban
conditions exactly like the ant beetle
did millions of years ago when it moved
inside
an ant colony we find now find animals
and plants that have moved inside
the human colony and are adapting to our
cities
and in doing so we're also beginning to
realize that
evolution can actually proceed very fast
it does not always take the long lapse
of ages it can happen under our very
eyes
this for example is the white footed
mouse
this is a native mammal from the area
around new york
and more than 400 years ago before the
city was built this mouse lived
everywhere
but these days they are stuck in little
islands of green the city's park
surrounded by a sea
of tarmac and traffic
a bit like a modern day version of
darwin's finches on the galapagos
and like darwin's finches the mice
in each separate park have started
evolving
have started to become different from
each other and this is my colleague
jason munshi south from fordham
university
who is studying this process he is
studying the dna of the mice
the white-footed mice in new york city's
parks
and trying to understand how they are
beginning to evolve in that
archipelago of eyelets and he's using a
kind of dna fingerprinting and he says
if somebody gives me a mouse
doesn't tell me where it's from just by
looking at its dna i can tell exactly
from which park
it comes that's how different they have
become
and jason has also discovered that those
changes these evolutionary changes are
not random they mean something
for example in central park
we find that the mice have evolved genes
that allow them to deal with very fatty
food human foods
25 million people visit central park
each year it's the most heavily visited
park in north america
and those people leave behind snack
foods and
and peanuts and junk food and the mice
have started feeding on that and it's
completely different diet than what
they're used to
and over the years they have evolved to
suit this very fatty very human diet
and this is another city slicker animal
this is the european garden snail
very common snail it comes in all kinds
of
color variations ranging from
from pale yellow to dark brown and those
colors are completely determined by the
snail's dna
and those colors also determine
the heat management of the snail that
lives inside that shell
for example a snail that sits in the
sunlight in the bright sun
if it has a pale yellow shell it doesn't
heat up as much
as a snail that sits inside
a dark brown shield just like when
you're sitting in a in a white car
you stay cooler than when you're sitting
inside a black car
now there is a phenomenon called the
urban heat islands
which means that in the center of a big
city the temperature can be several
degrees higher
than outside of the big city this has to
do with the fact that you have these
concentrations of millions of people
and all their activities and their
machineries they generate heat
also the wind is blocked by the tall
buildings
and all the the steel and brick and
concrete absorb the solar heat
and they radiate it out at night so you
get this bubble of hot air in the center
of a big city
and my students and i figured that maybe
those garden snails with their
variable shells are adapting
to the urban heat islands
maybe in the center of the city we find
that the shell color is evolving
in a direction to reduce overheating of
the snails
and to study this we started a citizen
science project
we built a free smartphone app which
allowed people all over the netherlands
to take pictures of snails in their
garden in their street
also in the countryside and upload them
to a citizen science web
platform and over a year we got 10 000
pictures
of snails that had been photographed in
the netherlands and when we started
analyzing the results
we found that indeed our suspicions were
confirmed in the center of the urban
heat island
we find that the snails have evolved
more
yellow more lighter colored shells
now the city snail and the manhattan
mouse are just two examples
of a growing list of animals and plants
that have evolved to suit this new
habitat this
city habitat that we have created and in
a book that i've written about this
subject
the subject of urban evolution i give
many more examples for example
weeds that have evolved seeds that are
better at germinating on the
grasshoppers that have evolved
a song that has a higher pitch when they
live close to noisy traffic
mosquitoes that have evolved to feed on
the blood
of human commuters inside metro stations
and even the common city pigeon that has
evolved
ways to detox themselves from heavy
metal pollution by
putting it in their feathers biologists
like myself
all over the world are becoming
interested in this fascinating process
of urban evolution we are realizing that
we're really at
a unique event in the history of life on
earth a completely new ecosystem
that is evolving and adapting to a
habitat that we have created
and not not just academics we're also
beginning to enlist the millions of
pairs of hands and ears and eyes that
are present in the city citizen
scientists
school children together with them we're
building a global
observation network which allows us to
watch this process of urban evolution
taking place
in real time and at the same time this
also
makes it clear to people that evolution
is not just some abstract thing that you
need to travel to the galapagos to to
study or that you need to be
a paleontologist for to understand what
it is
it's a very ordinary biological process
that's
taking place all the time everywhere
in your backyard in the street where you
live right outside of this theater
but there is of course a flip side to my
enthusiasm
when i go back to the village where i
grew up i no longer find those
fields and swamps that that i knew from
my youth
the village has now been absorbed by the
growing conglomeration of rotterdam
and instead i find shopping malls and i
find
suburbs and bus lanes and many of the
animals and plants that
i was so accustomed to have disappeared
including perhaps
that and beetle but i take comfort
in the fact that the children growing up
in that village today
may no longer be experiencing that
traditional nature that i grew up with
but they're surrounded by a new type of
nature a new type of ecosystem
that to them might be just as exciting
as the old type
was to me they're living in a new modern
day
galapagos and by teaming up with
citizen scientists and with evolutionary
biologists like myself
they might become the darwins of the
21st century
studying urban evolution thank you